hier matin le grand père de
richard keys ou se retrouver devant les
poké mais je sais pas et cela dès qu'on
quitte je suis tombé les primes qui donc
lire un film assez jeune des trois
seulement pourquoi bon je suis pas trop
en colère est-ce que c'est leur faut
pour faute aux parents c'est pas son
joueur qu'il emmenait les pieds
l'entente de kind on n'est pas arrivé on
n'est pas redescendue au poste ils sont
dehors parce qu'ils sont mineurs mais en
attendant la responsabilité il a friend
aller frapper une personne âgée en plus
par le tapage rica une personne 89 ans
qui tient à peine debout allait mettre
un coup un bel en convient mais derrière
la tête mais c'est pour la tuer bonjour
c'est pour la tuer c'est parce que vous
avez moi quand j'ai vu les premières
photos
j'ai dit ma mère elle est mortelle
vraiment il n'ya pas aucun sentiment de
regret de la part de ces jeunes aussi
qui tue on dit quoi saison quand même
lié pendant 24 heures iman